well Andrew McPhillips is chief
economist at the Yorkshire Building
Society jean-marc VanDerveer I used to
head up the residential arm of the
commercial property developer British
land and it's now chief executive of the
rental housing provide a platform and
Stewart Baisley the executive chairman
of Home Builders Federation is in our
central London studio Andrew let me
start with you I mean apart from London
is there genuinely a housing shortage
around the country I mean after all
household formation over the last few
years has fallen well short of
government predictions about 1.2 million
in fact I think if we look at
affordability we can see that that's
getting stretched right across the
country and it's about delivering
quality homes where people want to live
that are affordable whether that's to
purchase or indeed to rent but the how
the housing supply and demand factors
here isn't the big fattie what's really
stoked up to mind it's not so much a
supply-side crisis as the fact that
we've had ultra low interest rates for
nine years and that's just stoked up
demand yeah there has been an effect
from the interest rate policy and and
policies such as help to buy there
certainly increased on the demand side I
think it's fair to say we haven't seen
as big a response from the supply side
as one would have hopes given that you
know increase in demand so what have you
made of today you are quite impressed or
I think there are some warm words in
there to welcome I think particularly
looking at local authorities being given
more power to get involved in delivering
housing projects but I think as always
with these policies it's a case of it
actually being followed through with
action on the ground you're Maki you
operate in the rental sets you're a big
rental provider right it looks like the
government after years of talking about
home ownership is talking about rental
in a serious way you encouraged by that
yes we are we take the white paper as
very good news because the previous
government was focusing solely on the
home ownership and and the housing issue
is a massive issue and it cannot be
tackled only in one way it needs to be
tackled in different ways and covering
the different tenure social housing
private rented and the home ownership as
well but so far the previous years
people who have been left in the middle
who cannot afford or don't want to buy
yet and are not benefiting from the
social housing have been left on the
side
as there hasn't been any proper product
developed for their needs because out of
out of the total market basically 98% of
the houses for rent are managed by
individual angles not professional
manuals and there is the need for
product and the government does
understand that and they are providing
support for new companies like ours to
be able to develop those products okay
what Stewart basically in Westminster
we've heard loads of government attempts
to remedy the housing market and pep up
building over the years is there
anything genuinely new in this white
paper as far as you're concerned what
it's building on some of the policies
that have been around for the last five
or six years you're quite right we have
heard a lot about housing because people
like me and others have been talking
about a housing crisis now for the best
part of a decade or more and I think
it's fair to say that this white paper
today it's a hundred pages deep it's
there's a lot for us all to absorb in it
and much of it is to be the subject of
consultation of course none of this
necessarily will make a huge difference
in the immediate short-term but there is
a genuine attempt here to get to grips
with the root cause of the problem and
as your other guests have mentioned to
recognize that we need to be providing
housing homes for people across the
country of all 10 years some for sale
for for buyers to buy in the traditional
way but for shared ownership and for
rent and for private rent as well as for
social rent at its heart it's also
tackling one of the biggest issues which
holds back development in our country
and that is the lack of a properly
structured planning process at local
authority level and there are a lot of
measures in the white paper which are
aimed at addressing that white paper
recognizes for example that some 40
percent of local authorities still don't
have a local plan in place and clearly
if you don't have a local plan then you
are planning to fail in terms of housing
deliveries so there is a lot to be
applauded in the white paper today
particularly in the way that it's going
about asking local authorities to work
with providers whether they be
developers or builders of homes for rent
or anybody else involved in the housing
space in making sure that the local
needs are robustly scientifically
so that each local authority has a very
good accurate idea of what the housing
needs in its locality going to be and
then measuring the delivery of those
homes across the five-year period of the
vehicle plan on an annual basis and
ensuring that sites are made available
for all sorts of developments not just
large developments but also developments
for small developers for retirement
developers for builders of homes for
rent and so on and so forth so that what
about your sector Stewart's
I mean one of the big things that's come
out of this today's it's something like
60% of prizes private housing is built
by just 10 firms now the government is
attempting to get more SMEs involved in
in-house building it's like are they
gonna succeed
well they've as I said they put in place
some ideas and some policies
particularly in how the local plans are
put in place which will help to redress
the decline in small and medium sized
enterprises which is really what has
been at the heart of this if you can
trace this back in a prepare ever
appeared to 25 years you know this
housing crisis is not something that's
just happened in the last five or six
years and it's not really happened as a
result of the economic recession it's
happened as a result of a succession of
policies which have failed to ensure
that we've been building enough heads
for a quarter of a century or more and
one of the effects of those policies has
been a dramatic decline in a number of
small and medium sized builders which we
define as builders producing a hundred
hands a year or less there were 12 and a
half thousand of those 25 years ago
today there are just two and a half
thousand of those and we have seen
dramatic growth in housing output over
the last three or four years which is
often overlooked when people talk about
what's actually happening in the housing
market housing numbers the number of
homes built has increased by 50% in the
last three years but pretty much all of
that growth has come from those larger
companies that you mentioned because
they're better financed and able to take
advantage of the ability to invest in
land and
and grow their businesses okay smaller
builders have struggled with both the
red tape and the regulation of the
planning system which all builders have
to grapple with but it's particularly
tough when you're a small Kenda with our
huge resources and they've also
struggled to gain development finance to
enable them and to invest in land and
grow their businesses jamort you were
nodding at some of Stuart's comments
about local authorities how receptive
are local councils I mean clearly the
government tried a few years ago to get
them to think more about planning needs
there was he haven't done so so planning
I think they've done some work but I
think they are not going fast enough
it's not moving fast enough and I think
in the white paper what is being
provided is additional resources to make
sure that local authority of the
capacity and the capabilities to to make
sure that the planning concerns are
being provided faster and sooner because
you know it would be more if we can
build faster as well that will help to
solve the housing crisis and there is
also an attempt for the government to
help educate the local authorities to
develop and promote as well the rental
product as well because this is really a
tenure that has been left on the side
for so many years and the local
authorities don't necessarily apart from
social housing understand very well that
tenure and the government is willing
really to support that tenure and help
them to understand it better and educate
it and I'm sure one of the things that a
lot of people talked about today but
didn't really appear that much in the
white paper was stamp duty it clearly is
something I mean the rental providers
dislike it private landlords find it an
issue now particularly since Osborne
jacked up per stamp duty on rental
properties you actually wanted to see
stamp duty switched from from buyers to
sellers yeah we were looking at kind of
flipping it around so you get rid of a
first-time buyer ever having to stump up
front cost somewhere like London it's a
significant barrier to getting on the
property ladder for an average
first-time buyer that we lent to they'd
be looking at over ten thousand pounds
as an an upfront bill so switching it to
the seller they've got the cash from the
proceeds that their sale to pay it more
easily at the top of the market that was
talked about downsizing and perhaps some
support their elderly homeowners from
downsizing yeah and I think what we were
looking at you could introduce some
farmers exemption for people that were
looking to downsize if that's what they
want to do it would
them move into a smaller property that
suited to their needs if they want to do
that right Andrew Phillips John Marvin
Aviva answer your Baisley thanks all
thank you